i want to talk about a new example of an
inductor circuit and we have one shown
here
where this inductor is now controlled by
a switch this is this is a push button
switch that we move in and out
and this metal plate here will touch
these two contacts and complete this
circuit here
this is a lot like the circuit we looked
at before
without the switch where the voltage
source had a pulse going up and down
this this circuit has a real interesting
side effect when this switch opens up
so let me give you a couple of examples
first some practical examples of where
this kind of an inductor will appear
connected to a voltage source and
controlled by a switch
and there's a couple of examples one of
one of them is called a solenoid
and a solenoid is a coil of wire that
looks like this
and has a has a metal
rod going through it
when you put a pulse of current into
this what happens is the rod moves
the rod will move back and forth so this
is a way for instance a doorbell a
doorbell is this kind of a actuator
another kind of device that has an
inductor in it
or a coil is called a relay
and that one again has a coil like this
and
these are all forms of an electromagnet
and this one actually has a a switch
some sort of a a piece of metal that
will move back and forth
when the coil is energized this piece of
metal will actually tip over here
and when the current stopped it'll move
back to its original state
so for example if there's if there's a
connection point here
and a connection point here
this piece of metal will go from making
a short across there and move away and
open and close this bigger switch
so a relay is some sort of a switch
and you might find this in a car
where this relay is controlling like the
windshield wipers of a car where the
current for the windshield wiper goes
through this switch and there's a
smaller current over here
that pulls the switch open and closed to
start and stop
the windshield wipers or the motor
and that's just two examples of where
inductors or windings of wire can show
up in in real applications and there's
some fairly large currents that flow
through these windings
so we want to look what happens when we
switch this current on and off and this
is the example circuit that we'll use
so we'll assume we have a inductor of 10
millihenries
and what we're going to do is we're
going to push this push button switch
down and connect it up and then we're
going to let it go
and we're going to look at a couple of
different voltages here
this is going to be we'll call this
voltage v
and that's going to be measured with
respect to ground
and there's another voltage here
that's interesting too which is vl
and that's the voltage across the
inductor
so v
plus vl is equal to 3 volts all the time
and now we look at what happens when we
push the button down
and then after that we'll look at what
happens when we let go of the button
something interesting is going to happen
when we let go of this button
so as we look at our circuit here we see
there's an open circuit
so there's no current flowing in here
and that means i
equals zero
we'll call that i zero because it's the
initial current when
um we close our switch
so now let's close our switch we'll do
that like this
and we just closed our switch at time t
equals zero
and let's look at what happens all of a
sudden now
our inductor has a voltage across it
and it's a voltage of
this node is at three volts this node is
at zero volts so all of a sudden we have
three volts across our inductor
so let's use the integral form of the
inductor equation
to solve for the current
that's going to happen here
i equals 1 over l
times the integral
from 0 to t
of
v
d tau
plus
i zero
let's fill in what we know
i equals one over ten millihenries
and
v is a constant v is a constant 3 volts
times 3
and it's the integral
of d
tau from zero to t
and i zero is zero
and then we get the final form which is
i equals
three over ten millihenries
times the integral from zero to t of d
tau
is just t
and that's the answer so what we have
here just like we did before when we had
the the switching power supply
just like we had before we we're going
to get a current that has a ramp that
looks like that
the slope of that is 3
over 10 millihenries
which equals
300
amps
per second
so
oh my goodness this current is going up
really fast that's the slope of that
current right there this is going up
really fast and that's what it does now
in a real circuit there'll be real
resistances in here
but it uh and so there there'll be a
limit to the amount of current that will
be determined by the resistor but for
the purposes of showing you just how
this this inductor equation works that's
this kind of slope you would see at the
initial closing of the switch
okay i wanna i'm gonna clean off the
screen here so i can keep my same
circuit
and now we're going to look at what
happens here
when we open this switch let me open the
switch
and now we've opened our switch back up
it went that way
all right so
we have an initial current
and it's it's some it's going to be some
value depending on how long we held the
switch down
so it's going to be some current
and that's flowing in the inductor
now let's look at what happens when we
open the switch and all of a sudden
i goes directly and sharply to zero
that's what the switch does when we open
this switch contact
one moment it's touching and the other
moment it's not touching
so if we look at what's delta i or
what's di
it's the ending current
minus the starting current minus i
and if we look at what's the time
involved what's the change in time
involved in opening a switch
well it's something like
zero
the switch was closed then it was open
and that's how much that take that took
let's say that took zero time to happen
now here's something that happens with
inductors
that is kind of strange
let's calculate the voltage on the
inductor right when this happens
and we know that v equals
l times di
dt
and plug in some numbers here so we have
v
equals l times what d i
is minus i
over what
over zero
and that equals what that equals
negative infinity
what the heck is going on here is that
possible
no it's not
well let's okay let's let's take a
second let's say the switch didn't open
in zero time let's say the switch let's
say dt
was
um
let's say it was one nanosecond let's
give it some time to open up
all right that maybe that'll save us
maybe that'll make more sense okay let's
do that let's go
v equals l
times d i dt and d i we decided was
minus i
over
it took one nanosecond to open the
switch
one nanosecond is one
times ten
to the minus nine
okay so what does that equal to that
equals l
negative l times i
times 10
to the holy cow
10 to the plus 9.
okay let's let's plug in some real
values and see what we get here
let's say let's say v
equals let's say l was 10 millihenries
and let's say i was was 10 milliamps
flowing down through the
so delta i is minus 10 milliamps
and
the time involved is 10
to the minus 9 seconds
what does that work out to
10 millihenries that's minus 3
and minus 3.
so it's going to be 100
minus
minus 3 minus 3 is minus 6 over minus 9
times 10 to the third
okay that is
and there's a minus sign here this says
that v
this point right here
or the voltage across the inductor
our calculation just said it's going to
be a hundred
minus a hundred thousand volts
now minus a hundred thousand volts means
that the negative terminal
is a hundred thousand volts above the
positive terminal so this voltage v is
actually
at a hundred and ten thousand volts how
can this
be this is a puzzle about inductors that
we actually have to solve by actually
looking right up close at what's going
on here right in this switch area here
so this is where reality comes in and
saves us from our
the crazy results we're getting from our
ideal
um
equations here so let's pretend here's
here's the uh
here's the the terminal of the switch
right here let's do a blow up and here's
here's that switch plate
as soon as this switch moves away
there's an air gap created here
in our ideal world this air gap was a
perfect insulator but what's going to
happen because of these extreme numbers
here because of this is happening
this air gap is actually not an ideal
conductor and what's going to happen is
we're going to get a bright spark goes
right across here
this this really happens in real life
there is actually when you open a switch
there can be a little spark that goes
between and that gives this equation
here this d i d t
enough time to release that energy and
that current from the inductor continues
to flow and go over into the switch that
current will flow and it does it by
breaking down air molecules
and when you do that that voltage there
for air if this gap here
if this gap is one millimeter
for air that's 3000 volts
3000 volts will cause that spark to
happen there
this is what actually happens it and you
can build switches that will take this
spark and work for many years but it's
not always a good idea to let this
happen